In 1994, French director Luc Besson
unveiled his latest movie: Léon:
The Professional. This action-thriller centers
on the titular hitman, played by Jean Reno,
who ends up taking a young girl named Mathilda
under his wing after her family is killed. The
actress who played Léon's protégée was none
other than Natalie Portman, and her decision
to join the production at just 11 years old
marked the beginning of her big-screen journey.
Portman's portrayal of Mathilda didn't go
unnoticed, and with each subsequent role she took,
her stock in Hollywood grew dramatically
higher. It was during the 2000s that she
really made waves, however, with movies
such as V for Vendetta and Garden State.
The next decade kept her busy too, with projects
including Black Swan, Thor, and Annihilation.
These days, Natalie Portman is a household name,
having taken on several career-defining projects,
earned numerous awards, and used her platform to
spread awareness on issues near and dear to her.
However, thanks to one now-beloved
science-fiction blockbuster,
all of this success could very
well have never come to fruition.
1999 was a huge year for Natalie Portman,
seeing as it was the year she joined the
cast of Star Wars: Episode I – The
Phantom Menace. Portman starred as
Padmé Amidala: the queen of Naboo and an
eventual key figure in the Galactic Senate,
as well as the future wife of Anakin Skywalker
and the mother of their twins, Luke and Leia.
Naturally, landing a job like that should be the
single-greatest career move she could ever make,
right? Well, not exactly — since George
Lucas' second Star Wars trilogy was met
with some seriously harsh reactions from
critics. Not to mention the fact that the
fandom fractured with each passing installment,
putting immense pressure on the cast and crew.
For Natalie Portman specifically, Revenge of
the Sith came scarily close to ending her run
on the silver screen. She did what she could
with Lucas' notoriously weak dialogue and
tried to give a convincing performance — but
evidently it wasn't enough for most audiences.
By her own admission to New York
Magazine in 2014, she struggled to find
acting parts in the wake of her stint in
a galaxy far, far away. Noting that Star
Wars led many in the industry to believe
she was a bad actress, Portman recalled:
"I was in the biggest-grossing movie of the
decade, and no director wanted to work with me."
One likely reason for Natalie Portman losing
Hollywood's good graces post-Star Wars
had to do with the direction of Padmé
Amidala's story. In The Phantom Menace,
she was introduced as the intelligent, determined
leader of Naboo, who fought back valiantly against
the Separatist invaders. Then, in Attack
of the Clones, she showed that she wasn't
afraid to take the fight to her enemies on
the battlefield of Geonosis, or break every
rule in the book to be with her true love. By the
time Revenge of the Sith rolled around, however,
much of Padmé's character development
and personality had suddenly disappeared.
As a result of Padmé's reduced role in the story,
Portman didn't have a lot to sink her teeth
into during filming on Revenge of the Sith.
Her work amounted to delivering a few lines
now and again and crying before somehow dying
of sadness — something the film itself did a
poor job of explaining. The movie effectively
relegated Padmé to a plot device designed to
sell moviegoers on Anakin's transformation
into Darth Vader. That's certainly not a
great look for Portman herself, of course,
and things weren't helped along by the fact that
many of her better scenes were cut. In particular,
one subplot involving Padmé helping found the
Rebel Alliance wound up on the cutting room floor.
"We are not separatists trying
to leave the Republic. We are
loyalists trying to preserve
democracy in the Republic."
"I can't believe it has come to this."
It's plain enough to see that the actress and her
character both got the short end of the stick.
Thankfully, it didn't take too long
for the stigma of Revenge of the Sith
to wear off and for acting gigs to
come Natalie Portman's way once again.
Her career is still very much intact — and will
hopefully remain as such well into the future.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.